they will bring all of the crap back
don't believe me well Anthony fauci's
back here he is yesterday and yeah he
still wants you to get injected with his
experimental stuff the updated the
bivalent covet boosters
um that they work about as well as the
original boosters but no better which
had of course been hoped that they would
be kind of they would be more protective
if you will when the researchers
compared the immune responses of people
who got a booster dose of the original
shot to the people who got the updated
by valent coveted booster shots
um they they looked the way that the
research shows is they looked about the
same is that disappointing news
right
well if that is the case it's not that
disappointing because both of them work
very well I might comment that those
studies they came from very good
institutions and very good investigators
both of whom I know well
but they're still not peer-reviewed and
the numbers in those studies were small
right what I'm really looking forward to
Kate is the full data that we'll be
getting hopefully within the next couple
of weeks at the latest from the FDA who
will get the totality of the data that
was submitted to them by the companies
that did the study so I think the jury
is still out about that but even if it
turns out they're equivalent they both
did very well which means there's no
reason not to and a very good reason to
get your updated booster shot all right
that's absolutely right it had me
thinking about just how you have to
especially with the influenza vaccine
how you have to plan ahead
that's absolutely right that's
absolutely right oh my God I'm such a
journalist that's absolutely right um
sure the last booster didn't really work
and we all kind of know it which is why
everybody has 87 boosters and the head
of the CDC wolensky she has covet right
now besides 17 boosters and 87 other
shots and everything else oh you're just
you're just so good you're such a good
man who's watching this anyway the point
is the first booster it just really
didn't work and we all know it and we
know that the vaccines don't stop
transmission and all of that stuff and
now they're saying the new booster isn't
any better but he has to keep the grift
going he's he's so in on it and the guy
is worth five million more dollars than
he was worth two years ago he's gotta
keep the thing going